Hello, everyone, and welcome to this introductory session
on photogrammetry.
My name is Amir Yassin, and I will be your host.
In this class, you learn about photogrammetry,
the art of turning 2D pictures into 3D models.
You learn about how to set the stage
and take pictures correctly, what hardware
to use for an efficient photo shoot,
understand the limitations that are inherent with surface
properties, and discuss several software choices
so that you are familiar with various solutions.
You will learn about the pros and cons
of using photogrammetry with a smartphone
app versus the professional way
of using a more robust desktop application.
For our purposes, we'll be using RealityCapture, Epic
Games' own photogrammetry solution.
And so if you're ready, let's start.